thank you very much on behalf of Terry
Martin the director of the Davis center
and Alexander Baku the executive
director of the Davis centre and the
Harriman Institute I want to welcome you
to our event today how central is
Central Asia
my name is Timothy freh I am the
director of the Harriman Institute and
for many years the Davis centre and the
Harriman Institute have been running
joint conferences typically they were
more exclusive affairs more focused on
business issues and we wanted to shake
things up a little bit this year and we
wanted to have a much more policy
oriented event a more public event and
we wanted to keep all the good things of
the the old Herman Davis Center series
by having excellent speakers and having
lots of opportunities for the audiences
to ask questions as well as to introduce
some changes we will be podcasting and
video taping the event today so I assume
that the speakers have no objections and
just so you know that any comments and
questions will be out there for eternity
on YouTube probably at some point so
keep that in mind when I say I would end
when answering your questions we have
really a terrific panel today with four
terrific panels today actually it's my
job to introduce the first panel and we
have fairly extensive bios of the
authors so I won't go into all their
luminous paths but just to briefly
introduce our panel today we have Tom
Graham Lewis senior director at
Kissinger associates Alexander Cooley
associate professor of political science
at Barnard College Columbia University
Jason Lisle assistant professor of
political science at Yale and Laura
lumpy who's our consultant it was a
consultant at open society institute and
the open society
Apolo Policy Center what I'll do is I'll
ask East each of our speakers to talk
for about 12 to 15 minutes and then I
will try to provoke spark some
discussion among the panelists based on
their comments and then we'll turn the
floor over to the audience to ask
questions and if you could line up
behind the the podium when we get to
that point that would be greatly
appreciated so please join me in
welcoming Tom Graham of Kissinger
associates will be our first speaker for
the day thank you very much thank you
very much Tim and thanks to the Harriman
Institute for putting on this this event
today I was first engaged in
policymaking on Central Asia about 20
years ago so right after the breakup of
the of the Soviet Union I was working at
the State Department the policy planning
staff and we were doing a session with
other people from the government on
Tajikistan the mounting unrest civil war
in Tajikistan and one of the
participants asked how are we going to
bring the power of the 6th fleet in the
Mediterranean to bear on this conflict
and that's when I formulated my first
rule on policymaking and that is that
policy makers should be forbidden for
making policy towards countries they
can't locate on a map now we've done a
little bit better since then and I'm
sure Kurt Donnelly will be speaking
later this afternoon knows exactly where
Tajikistan is in Central Asia I also
noticed that I think in deference to a
question I've asked we've actually put a
question mark at the end of this this
session on how central the central asia
to central the international security I
think that's appropriate because there
is a debate about that and it's not
immediately obvious 13 years ago in 1977
significance key devote an entire
chapter what to what he called Eurasian
Balkans that is Central Asia the
caucuses in Afghanistan in his book the
grand chessboard it was one of four
zones in you in your age landmass where
the future of American primacy was going
to be determined according to version
scheme but in his view it paled in
comparison to the other three zones
Europe and East Asia where the United
States was directly engaged and to what
he called the black hole or Russia
which has historically been a great
power and a geostrategic
player the competition that Brzezinski
foresaw was among Russia Turkey and Iran
perhaps in time China's a competition
that was hardly central to your
international security in 1997 and not
to American primacy in Brzezinski's view
the United States was too distant to be
the dominant force in the Eurasian
Balkans but too powerful not to be
engaged in some way and he insisted that
our interest our national interest
wasn't inventing any single power for
dominating the region and from ensuring
that the that the the global community
had unhindered financial and economic
access to this region now the United
States government since the breakup of
the Soviet Union has more or less
adhered to a vergence keys assessment of
the centrality of Central Asia very
telling are the national security
documents that have been released by the
by the US government by the White House
since 9/11 since the time that the
United States inserted its troops into
Central Asia to prosecute the war
against al-qaeda and a and and the
Taliban in Afghanistan the national
security strategy released earlier this
year the first by the Obama
administration simply does not mention
central asia in any significant way the
first one issued by the Bush
administration in 2002 after we were
already involved in Afghanistan
mentioned Central Asia but in the
context of energy and energy security
the most extensive discussion of Central
Asia comes in the national security
strategy of 2006 by the Bush
administration and it devoted a
paragraph to Central Asia that reads as
follows Central Asia is an enduring
priority for our foreign policy the five
countries of Central Asia are distinct
from one another and our relations with
each while important will differ in the
region as a whole the elements of our
lack larger strategy
and we must pursue those elements
simultaneously promoting effective
democracies and expansion of free market
reforms diversifying global energy
sources of energy and enhancing security
and winning the war on terror and that's
pretty inspiring stuff I was actually in
the White House at that time and I
participated in drafting the national
security strategy and I can tell you
that we draft paragraphs like that well
you don't know what to say about the
region we're dealing with but we know
that it has to be in the strategy
someplace now it's quite clear that
despite this that the United States has
devoted some attention to Central Asia
since the breakup of the Soviet Union
the United States has sought to enhance
the sovereignty and independence of the
states of the region and it sought to
limit the the reassertion of Russian
influence in that part of the world and
throughout the former Soviet space in
part to prevent the re-emergence of a
threat of Soviet dimensions to American
national security the United States has
also sought to develop the energy
resources of the region to bring them to
global markets particularly European
markets traversing Russian and Iranian
territory and in part to limit the
chances of the the possibilities for
Russia to reassert its influence in that
part of the world and more recently as
we all know the United States has
inserted military forces into Central
Asia to aid the campaign in Afghanistan
and also now in process developing a
distribution network that we hope will
provide a reliable alternative to an
increasingly tenuous situation in
Pakistan but throughout this period no
senior US government official has
claimed that Central Asia per se is
critical to u.s. security to our
strategic goals nor has the
administration or the government as a
whole developed a comprehensive and
coherent strategy towards Central Asia
over the past two decades nor have we
devoted a considerable amount of
resources to it
in short Central Asia had never figured
at the top of the list of American
national security priority
and in this the United States is not
different from the other major powers
Central Asia is an afterthought for the
European Union and leading European
powers which right now are much more
focused on their Mesnick internal
problems and they are on foreign policy
or asserting their their presence abroad
China clearly has penetrated Central
Asia over the past decade its reasoning
completed two pipelines from the Caspian
to Chinese markets but Central Asia for
the Chinese takes a backseat to Taiwan
Northeast Asia Russia India the United
States and so on
India is focused on growing Chinese
influence in its immediate neighbourhood
but not on the Chinese presence in
Central Asia India is also fixated on
its complicated
and competitive hostile relationship
with Pakistan which extends Afghanistan
but not the Central Asia if there's an
exception it is Russia which has spent
the past decade trying to reassert its
influence throughout the former Soviet
space including Central Asia with
respect to Central Asia itself Russians
have tried to main their dominant
position in that part of the world to
dominate the export routes of energy
from Central Asia they sought to
maintain themselves as a dominant
security actor in the region in part
through the collective security treaty
organization and they sort the organized
economics of this region in part through
the Eurasian Economic Community but
Moscow has pursued all of these policies
not so much because Moscow believes that
Central Asia is central the
international security that's because
Moscow believes that its presence in
that part of the world in the former
Soviet space it's critical to its status
as a major world power so there's little
evidence in the policies and postures of
the major powers that would suggest that
Central Asia is central in
national security now I've worked long
enough in government in both Republican
and Democratic administrations to know
that governments don't always know what
their best interests are and they don't
always get it right
and in particular when governments are
focused on the pressing issues of today
there's precious little time to devote
to thinking about new and future
challenges
so the question that we need to ask
today is what perhaps the major powers
have missed about central asia i had a
bearing on its role in global security
and the way to start to answer that
question is to ask ourselves what has
changed in the 13 years since big
Brzezinski wrote his book on the grand
chessboard
now first Pierzynski was absolutely
right the states of the region remain
fragile poverty is widespread ethnic
tensions are high and arguably the
situation has deteriorated over the past
13 years we've seen rising instability
and extremism throughout the region in
part as a consequence of developments in
Afghanistan Kyrgyzstan has witnessed two
coos and the current arrangement about
which I think we'll talk more in this
afternoon doesn't look particularly
stable in Tajikistan in recent months
we've seen growing tension and growing
unrest and a growing extremist threat to
this to the state and in two key states
of the region Kazakhstan and Uzbekistan
we are almost inevitably going to see a
transition over the next decade a
transition that could be not only from
one leader to another leader but a
generational shift and such transitions
will test the robustness of the
political systems in both countries
second we've seen the emergence of two
new nuclear powers in Central Asia's
neighborhood Pakistan and India which
tested their weapons in 1998 and have
developed substantial Arsenal since and
we have a third country in
hood iran which at a minimum is trying
to master the technology that will allow
it to build nuclear weapons third we've
seen china move aggressively into the
region over the past decade to the
extent that china has probably overtaken
russia as a leading commercial partner
central asia states and its pipeline
strategy has begun to challenge russian
domination and monopoly of export routes
fourth we see more generally a growing
emergence of East and South Asia as meet
major economic and geopolitical players
in the world and this has enhanced the
role of Central Asia as a land corridor
between two major economic zones Europe
East and South Asia but also as possibly
a region of sharpening geopolitical
competition for the resources of Central
Asia particularly energy that are
necessary for continued economic growth
in both those two zones Europe and East
and South Asia and finally over the past
decade we've witnessed a remarkable
economic recovery Bua by Russia a Russia
that has regained some of his
international standing and a Russia that
within the past several years has
forsaken its original goal of
integrating with the West in favor of
playing a role as an independent pole of
power in the international system and
this is a country that as I've already
said sees Central Asia as critical to
its standing in the world and has moved
into that region with great deal of
resources in the past several years and
more important it has aligned itself at
times with China to counter US influence
in that part of the world so Central
Asia has become a much more volatile
power in regions over the past 13 years
but I still think something's lacking to
make central asia central at the global
security it's hard to imagine a credible
Central Asian scenario that leads to a
major conflict between Russia China and
the United States
in the next decade it's hard to imagine
a threat of global dimensions emanating
from Central Asia proper the missing
element in my mind is Afghanistan a
region of growing instability
instability that is impacting on the
entire neighborhood both Central and
South Asia but also Southwest Asia as
well and this is a region that has
enhanced and increased the extremist
threat to its neighborhood it's a region
where the explosive growth in drug
trafficking has had deleterious
consequences for Russia the Central
Asian states themselves and Iran and in
particular we've seen growing
geopolitical competition among Russia
the United States and China something
that is certainly more important to
global security than the type of
geopolitical calm competition that
Brzezinski contemplated a little over a
decade ago moreover as the United States
withdraws from Afghanistan something
that's going to happen if not next
summer in the distant future we're going
to see a growing need for a security
structure in that part of the world that
provides for stability in Afghanistan
that prevents growing geopolitical
competition both inside Afghanistan and
in its neighborhood the immediate threat
I would argue is some major conflict
between Pakistan and India one that
almost certainly will not start in
Afghanistan but would extend us to
Afghanistan and the growing instability
in Afghanistan itself increases the
dangers of instability in Central Asia
to the global to the global security
environment think about the possibility
of an explosion the Fergana Valley an
explosion that clearly would have
serious consequences for the three
countries that occupy that Valley but
also serious consequences for Russian
interest in Central Asia and American
interest
in Afghanistan what the consequences
would be of an explosion there for the
interaction between Russia and the
United States and Central Asia and South
Asia is an open question let alone what
the reaction would be of the other major
powers in the region so to sum up I
think it's very difficult to make an
argument that Central Asia itself is
central to Europeans or to international
security but you combine South Asia with
Central Asia and I think you have a
powerful argument that this is going to
be central to the international security
over the next decade and beyond in this
regard makes sense that the State
Department is combined South Asia and
Central Asia in a single Department in a
single Bureau at the Department I think
that's forward-looking in the way we
think about it the geopolitical
challenges we need but what's missing is
still a comprehensive coherent strategy
for Central and South Asia what's
missing is something that will put in
place an adequate security structure to
manage the relations in that part of the
world now and over the next decade and
beyond and absent that structure I would
argue we're going to see an increase in
the risk of major conflict between and
among the great powers in the future
perhaps not so much in this decade but
if we think beyond that certainly a
possibility and in that regard because
of that danger I think you can make a
persuasive argument that the US
government and other major powers should
be devoting more resources and time to
thinking hard about Central Asia and its
future role in the international
environment thank you
thanks very much so I'm gonna bring a
more scholarly perspective to some of
the issues that tom has been talking
about my own particular a kind of
theoretical sort of approach to sort of
working these things out and and and I
think underlying some of the points Tom
is making perhaps differing in a couple
of places I think tom is absolutely
right in terms of setting the bar high
looking at the International Security
importance of Central Asia think the
question and and and generally I agree
with them the question becomes a little
more complicated when we think about
what are the security dynamics within
Central Asia itself right what are the
main security objectives of what I call
the sort of the three great powers in
the region the United States China and
Russia and the merchants are strategic
triangle and this is a difficult
question to answer in part because both
the external and internal dynamics of
security in Central Asia are tied to the
great powers using the security issue
for their own instrumental purposes
right and then so what we tend to see is
the practice of strategic regionalism by
each of these three powers and attempt
to transform the region and to use it to
promote a security agenda that has
actually is that where Central Asia is
actually of secondary importance so let
me let me elaborate here first of all
for the US central asia is central to
the war in afghanistan right and the
fact ana stan is the main security
objective certainly for the obama
administration and it's escalation so
after 9/11 the united states establish
security cooperation support of
Operation Enduring Freedom and establish
military bases in southern news Pakistan
car Chicana bod the manoj base in
kyrgyzstan had agreed on refueling deals
with other Central Asian governments gas
and go arrangements as they were called
and and flyover rights there were a
series of
quid pro quos in these arrangements in
other words one of the things that the
US has constantly had to deal with is a
lot of the Central Asian governments
have behaved in a manner that's
inconsistent with their sort of public
speeches that Afghanistan is a security
threat to them in other words a lot of
Central Asian countries use the US
presence as an opportunity to extract
concessions from the US basing rents
security cooperation the type that Laura
will detail later on and a lot of this
economic aid was also done at the
personal level right so for instance in
the Mehnaz case that a lot of the
service contracts associated with Mehnaz
were targeted at the ruling elite first
the akai halves then the baqia --vs as a
way of gaining personal buy-in into
maintaining the US military presence so
Central Asian leaders have not always
been on the same page about
Afghanistan's importance they viewed the
US military presence as a way to extract
rents from these international sources
so for the u.s. this has become sort of
you know part of the you know part of
the challenge is to present sort of a
unified front with its Central Asian
partners on Afghanistan when in fact you
have this sort of dual purpose now
regarding comms point about sort of the
State Department move one of the things
that we've seen is that over the last
decade the sort of intensification of
perceptions of a great game being played
out right and and and and I'm not quite
sure who the great gamers really are in
terms of identifying them in the US and
China and Russia but oftentimes moves
are interpreted as signs of a great game
and I think the State Department move
was was one of those cases where a lot
of analysts in Beijing and in Moscow saw
this aha State Department is moving
Central Asia South Asia this is evidence
that the u.s. is interested in linking
up Central Asia to Afghanistan has
hegemonic ambitions in the region and so
forth now the first go-round of the u.s.
in Central Asia ended badly with
the eviction of the United States from
its k2 car Chicana baud base in
Uzbekistan as a result of mixed messages
mixed priorities being sent to the whose
Beck government with the instability in
Afghanistan rather Pakistan and sort of
supply routes there the US military has
returned to Central Asia not only
maintained its Mahna space through the
construction of the so-called northern
distribution network rnd in an attempt
to move material through Central Asia to
supply Afghanistan and and and I assume
Andy will have all the great slides for
us looking at some of the importance of
these transportation routes or later on
but we also see similar types of
dynamics of how ndn is viewed by the
Central Asian countries versus sort of
how we view them as central to the
Afghanistan campaign in other words
we've provided a lot of economic
incentives to do ndn we've provided some
aid some walking-around money that laura
sort of talks about and then the other
sort of consequence of this too is that
the kind of other parts of the portfolio
that tom was referring to in national
security strategy of 2006 have been
downplayed right play up afghanistan
play down issues of cert democracy and
human rights and and and so forth so
central asia important for the US but
because it's an instrument to
stabilizing Afghanistan I would argue
China's in quite a similar place that
for it Central Asia is not so important
but it's important in terms of
stabilizing its western province of
Xinjiang right and Chinese mechanisms of
influence are different right the u.s.
relies on military military contracting
economic aid and so forth China has
trying to channel its influence through
the creation of multilateral
organization called the Shanghai
Cooperation Organization right formerly
composed of China Russia four out of the
five Central Asian countries with the
exception of Turkmenistan which remains
neutral and the SEO s mission is
dedicated to combating this the three
so-called evil separatism terrorism
extremism right and so the Shanghai
Cooperation Organization was born out of
the shanghai five which was a group that
tried to delineate and finalized sort of
the borders all russian or rather
soviets I know conflicts and then
blossomed over the last decade into
doing more security cooperation now
what's interesting about the SCO
in relation to Western counterparts is
that it's a multilateral vehicle where
Beijing seems to be driving the agenda
but although it in some ways it's
similar in form to Western organizations
in substance it differs quite
extensively first of all the norms and
mission statement of the SEO is to
provide promote regional stability
cooperation across a broad array of
issue areas and to reject hegemony and
coercion in international relations this
is sort of a clear kind of reference to
the West it's a lot of SEO and
declarations emphasize maintaining or
respecting each other sovereignty right
non interference and domestic affairs
again sort of trying to contrast it
itself with other Western organizations
Western oriented organizations as the
OSCE or NATO that clearly do have
standards for domestic institutional
evolution now the security agenda has
seen in terms of combating these three
the three evils has tended to focus on
domestic and transnational security
threats yes there are military exercises
that the SEO promotes but mostly in the
realm of sort of identifying militants
doing certain renditions security
promoting security cooperation between
security services the SEO has been
arguably effective there's a cyber
security aspect of this a transfer of
cyber technology and dissemination
especially through the regional
anti-terrorism center rats and there's
also a number of proposed other
initiatives beyond the security agenda
that China would like to pursue through
the SCO would like to pursue its
economic policies to establish a free
trade zone
to do all sorts of more things to
promote infrastructure development and
sent in SEO but for the most part that
agenda has been checked and it's been
checked mostly by Russia and sort of
growing suspicions about China's
influence and its use of the SEO as a
Chinese mechanism so it gets quite
confusing for researchers because a lot
of things that China does bilaterally in
Central Asia are referred to as SEO
after the fact right start trying figure
that is this really a CEO you know what
is it but again it's important for China
to put that multilateral face on on what
it's doing completely agree with Tom on
Russia's strategic interests and again
not the interest is not in the security
Central Asia itself but rather I see
sort of three related objectives first
is countering Western influence in the
Eurasian sphere and this especially
accelerated with the rise of the colored
revolutions right concerns about what
our military bases in Central Asia doing
are they doing just what we say that
they're doing in terms of stabilizing in
Afghanistan do they represent threats
against Russian interests in the region
and so forth
another type of objective is much more
intangible what tongs sort of talks to
to be respected to be acknowledged as
the hegemonic power in the region to
have status considerations taken
seriously to be deferred to to be
acknowledged and all this is much more
difficult to sort of operationalize in
an in a concrete sort of way where I and
and and it's certainly true that Moscow
and Russia of the three great powers has
by far the most levers of influence by
far the most mechanisms of soft power
media education security service
cooperation intelligence services kind
of a cultural affinity it controls the
passports and movements of hundreds of
thousands of labor migrants right from
especially from Tajikistan and
Kyrgyzstan so of all the powers Moscow
has the most levers right of influence
where Moscow gets itself in more of a
political pickle is in recent years as
it's tried to translate these levers of
influence into architectures of a
exclusive control right through
mechanisms like EurAsEC through
mechanisms like the customs union now
which involves Kazakhstan Russia and and
Belarus and through the csto on the
security side so one of the interesting
dynamics is this calm perception of a
short-lived alliance between China and
Russia to counter Western influence was
actually a product of a particular
circumstance was the colored revolutions
in 2005 you've seen some real
differences since then especially how
they approach the gorge ASU and so forth
let me briefly make a few just quick
observations on some of the competition
effects then of these different types of
strategic regionalism being promoted
first the intensification of the
perception of competition whether it's
reeled or not has empowered local elites
to try and access more rents more
revenues play powers off one another
invoke other powers in their dealing and
try to ignore the part of the agenda
that they don't like right
and I think you know Jays gonna say
something more about that political
stability this cuts both ways in the
smaller countries Kyrgyzstan Tajikistan
that have been engaging with the
external system and where revenues have
been concentrated and things like
foreign aid flows military related
payments basing you see more and more
short-term thinking and you see these
revenues sort of engorging ruling
regimes and not making their way through
the distribution system and I think you
know Erik might have something to say
about that and is Kyrgyzstan a panel so
we're at the point where Kyrgyzstan and
Tajikistan been stretched to the
breaking point was this caused by
external competition no the mechanism is
more complicated than that but certainly
there's a real difference between sort
of this is the stability situation in
these places in the way they're
interfacing and Kazakhstan Turkmenistan
where this is more about competition
over oil concessions and so forth final
point I want to make strategic
regionalism in the way all three
countries have practiced it has proven
wholly inadequate to address the actual
sources of insecurity in Central Asia
Institute
no weakness corruption security services
in the border guard local conflicts and
disputes the water rights disputes
between upstream countries and
downstream countries right Tajikistan
Kyrgyzstan Uzbekistan if there's ever
going to be a source of actual conflict
it's going to be water and in some ways
what the great powers have been doing
has played up some of these domestic
concerns so for instance when Russia
talks about wanting to put a base in
southern Kyrgyzstan for prestige reasons
this sends that ooze backs into a real
sense of concern well what's the Russian
base doing there right or when we talk
about doing more to mil-to-mil
cooperation in southern Kyrgyzstan very
similar perception so it's very
difficult to disentangle your strategic
objectives from these sort of local
types of issues so I'll leave it at that
perhaps in the Q&A we can talk a little
bit about Mehnaz but thank you very much
good morning I'd like to use my 12
minutes or so to be hopefully as
provocative as I possibly can and I'm
gonna leave aside most of the areas and
which actually do so we're actually
agree with my August panel members and
I'm gonna try and push back a little bit
and just to sort of lay my theoretical
priors or my empirical experiences on
the table I typically work in the
Northern Caucasus which is not normally
considered part of Central Asia but
today I'm going to sneak in a little bit
on the Northern Caucasus and in
Afghanistan now and while the two
presenters before gave us sort of 30,000
foot view great politics great power
politics I typically work at the village
level so the great powers going on up
there and I'm down here and I'm going to
try and give a bit of a perspective from
there although I realize to be an
international relations person so I'm
gonna try and rely on the great game
metaphors as well where I do agree is
that I think the United States does not
have a clear strategy toward Central
Asia even to this day I would actually
argue that Russia does not have a clear
and consistent strategy towards
Afghanistan or Central Asia today as
well but I think there's actually a
deeper problem just simply strategic
sort of ineffectiveness or strategic I
non clarity I think the toolkit for most
of these states is pretty much empty and
what we're seeing in Central Asia that
the mechanisms are the levers of
influence that these great powers have
are
running dry essentially they're not
working very effectively whether that
ranges the ranges from military force in
Afghanistan we're seeing the limits of
what can be accomplished with military
force that goes to economic and
development aid which I'll talk a little
bit about today which is actually having
a number of pernicious influences on the
development of these states and of
spreading the conflicts rather than
ameliorating them I think we're seeing
the limits of democracy promotion either
through overt external intervention but
also to the more subtle kind of color
revolutions to pre-2005 era I think
we're seeing that those levers have very
very little influence on these
particular countries actually in Central
Asia actually sees Central Asian states
as much more resilient than I think most
people would I think their leaders have
made effective use of their strategic
levers and their particular leverage
over the United States over Russia in
this region I think that they have acted
in some senses made very good use of
their weakness as a form of strength in
their bargaining relationships with the
great powers in the region and where I
see that the deepest threat to the
region right now is actually not in
insurgent violence it's actually in
corruption
I think corruption right now within the
center of five former Soviet republics
as well as within Afghanistan it's
probably the number one issue right now
it's also one of the hardest issues to
deal with in the region and I think
these sort of threat of Islamic
fundamentalism and particularly of a
united bloc or United groups moving
across this region is really overplayed
and so what I'd like to do is begin in
Afghanistan which I do agree with the
panelists I think that is the epicenter
I think that is why the United States
cares I think that some ways that's why
we're here today because it does matter
and then I'd like to just move out in a
concentric circle to what the impact of
Afghanistan is on the Central Asian
Republics that are neighbouring and then
I'm gonna take a two minute detour to
the Northern Caucasus which has many of
the same elements that Afghanistan does
the United States it does for Russia too
including the limits of a lot of the
levers of influence now we can spend a
lot of time talking about Afghanistan
and and the nature of the conflict and
the dynamics of it I assume most people
are familiar with the nature of it it's
obviously a very complicated case but I
want to just point out a few things that
I think are really important about
understanding it one is that the United
States has essentially tied its fortunes
in Afghanistan to what it looks like a
seemingly weak
as Karzai administration in Kabul and
has very very few levers of influence
over this particular regime and I think
this is actually something despite the
United States all its leverage this
military power to economic might it has
a hard time forcing Karzai to do
anything I think this is a broader
pattern actually of the interaction
between the great powers and so-called
weaker States in the region it's really
that these leaders are actually much
more harder to budge than we think they
are and so this notion of the weak
Central Asian states I think needs to be
recast because the leaders have a lot of
levers of influence the other thing that
Afghanistan shows us is the limits of
the toolkit that the great powers have
to actually shape events in this given
region the military power and we could
talk about the ineffectiveness or
seemingly ineffectiveness 9 years now to
trying to defeat the Taliban
and sort of the limits of what you can
achieve a military power but I actually
thought these more interesting talk
about the limits of what you can do with
economic aid and development aid in this
region because I think that carries deep
consequences for the other countries
because there's part of the strategy
that we're using in Afghanistan through
development aid is now being writ large
to the northern distribution network
into the other Central Asian Republics
and many of the issues and the negative
influences that are rising from aid in
Afghanistan I think will also spread
through the national news and
distribution network into the Central
Asian Republics as well and that may be
one of the mechanisms by which conflict
spreads not sort of this willy-nilly
notion as Islamic fundamentalists are
going to move across the border and
spread there's actually going to be a
deliberate or at least a clear mechanism
and it's gonna be part and parcel of
u.s. strategy not an intended
consequence but an unintended side
effect of these strategies so what's the
problem with aid in Afghanistan one of
the things is simply that it generates a
tremendous amount of corruption not just
among Karzai's administration this is
where we typically look but it bleeds
down into all of the organs of the state
down to the police down to the judicial
system right one of the things that the
United States is trying to do in
Afghanistan is create an effective state
but the corruption that's coming from
all of the aid meit is pouring in to
Afghanistan without a clear and
consistent program of actually assessing
the effectiveness of aid is generating
wild amounts of corruption and is
bleeding away the legitimacy of the
state in the eyes of the Afghan people
okay it's also generating hmm
this amount of violence in these areas
let me give you an example just a small
one one of the key staples of US aid
policy in Afghanistan is building roads
this should sound familiar because it's
what we're doing with the northern
distribution network as well but
Afghanistan was sort of the example of
building roads it will bring people
together it will generate an internal
market people can bring their goods and
services to bear we will create an
internal market and we will therefore
restore the legitimacy of the government
because people get back to work and
unemployed men are not shooting anymore
at US soldiers what we're finding out
now is as we build roads we generate
more violence why because the people who
did not get the contracts to build the
road now begin shooting at the people
who did get the contracts for the road
ok what else does it do it allows the
insurgents to move much more freely in
the conflict space they too can use the
roads the third thing that it does and
this is something we're going to see I
think as we extend the northern
distribution network outward it is
unique and it takes a public good which
is the road system and makes it a
private bill a private good why because
it allows insurgents but also police
militia groups to cut the road and put
tolls and transit routes up so that they
can fund their phone particular
activities we can not police along these
road systems anywhere near and the
depths that we would need and so what
happens is we are fueling criminal gangs
and insurgencies because we create the
road system that they then selectively
turn on and off and we can't catch them
before they do it tremendous amount of
the money from the Taliban is not is
part of it it's drug money but a lot of
it is revenues being extracted roadside
in flying tariffs and tolls ok so what
happens is if you have an AIDS strategy
that's designed to move in quickly
generate quick results and it does not
have a proper accounting system which is
a story in Afghanistan you will generate
more amounts of corruption you will
generate more amounts of violence rather
than exactly the opposite which is what
you're intending to do this is I think
an important example for what we may see
along the northern distribution network
now the idea with the northern
distribution network and this is part of
how Afghanistan will externalise it's
the negative consequences of Afghanistan
is that we will take this road system
and essentially repeat the same error
that is going to be it happen that are
happening now in Afghanistan we're
already starting to see it we're seeing
and now swing of violence up to the
north the Taliban are now incredibly
active in the north because they're
moving towards the northern distribution
networks most southern most point into
Afghanistan last in the last year or so
if you've ever had a chance to look at
WikiLeaks look at where the northern
violence the levels of northern violence
it's spiked dramatically the Taliban
have essentially flipped their strategy
from out of the south and into the north
part of that is as a consequence of the
northern distribution network is pushing
insurgency closer to the borders of the
Central Asian states now once this road
network moves through it will create
rent-seeking opportunities for militia
groups it will create rent-seeking
opportunities for these of police actors
inside the Central Asian states which
already have fairly low standards of
legitimacy what this could do is further
undermine the legitimacy of these
particular leaders creating instability
in Central Asia now to step back for a
moment Central Asia should be awash in
flames if you remember the early
pronouncements after the Soviet collapse
right this was going to be the arc of
instability this was going to be just a
tremendous amount of conflict and there
was some but surprisingly little given
all the precursors for what we think
should be there right we have low per
capita income now in this territory
leaders with low edge of legitimacy
non-democracies these are all the kind
of precursors for civil wars we haven't
really seen that the leaders themselves
have largely been able to insulate
themselves from the people since about
2005 in response to external democracy
promotion efforts so they have moved to
clamp down on points of dissent within
societies have moved to clamp down on
NGOs have clamped down in the media and
been able to manipulate their societies
with the recent exception thank you go
stand in April of 2010 but for the most
part there's a lot less conflict than we
would actually expect and these leaders
have been much more effective at
extracting concessions from the great
powers than we would otherwise expect
now this is probably an unstable balance
over time and one of the things that if
we're doing if we're not careful with
the NDN and other efforts like the
basing rights Alec spoke about is that
we may be generating
even more amounts of corruption not just
at the high levels but at the low levels
that force people to turn away from
their government and begin to seek other
alternatives because they believe
there's this totally illegitimate if you
look at Kyrgyzstan and I know we have a
panel on that so I won't speak very much
about that that was not really a color
revolution right it was movement against
a government policy one that the
government had really just asked too
much of the people now it was really
seen as illegitimate one of the dangers
is that that unstable equilibrium which
we may not necessarily like right
because it's undemocratic if there's
human rights abuses but really has not
been seen as a major concern for the
United States on national security
grounds one of the things that may
happen is that as we move into this
region we upset that particular
equilibrium and we allow for more
corruption and generate more social
oppressed against the particular states
so in this particular area we may see
Afghanistan spreading north the violence
spreading north not because of
connections between the insurgent groups
but because of localized responses to
various aid strategies and development
strategies that are being employed by
the different great powers in this
region this is not to say that the
violence will be automatic is that it's
a function a byproduct of US and Russian
in some cases Russian strategies in
these particular areas as well finally
just to shift a little bit to the to the
West with Russia we see the same kinds
of issues with strong leaders low levels
or ineffective levers of power over
leaders we see localized responses to
state brutality in Chechnya and in the
broader Northern Caucasus now as well
and one of the things that's most
worrisome in the Caucasus is really the
spread of violence outside of its
epicenter in Chechnya as well okay and
this is something we've seen actually
mirrors Afghanistan which we had low
levels of violence and then began to
spread this really is true two of the
caucuses in which Russian strategy in
many ways marginalized brutalized the
people and we led it led to an increased
insurgent response and so in this area
we see local leaders such as the leaders
of Chechnya for example who can exert
tremendous leverage over the Kremlin
strategy the crime
largely lost control I would argue of
the Northern Caucasus its strategies of
military power as being a coercive
apparatus have largely failed its form
of economic assistance has had exactly
the same effect that US assistance in
Afghanistan has which is to generate
large amounts of corruption which to
generate new rent-seeking actors who
have come into power and to violence in
order to capture some of these rents and
so we've seen a spreading of it because
these groups are rising to capture the
aid and the revenue we've seen
spectacular levels of corruption come
out of this region as well we've seen
rival actors now emerge who are
exercising governance other than the
state in these particular areas or large
swaths of Afghanistan that are now
outside Kabul control that's actually
true of the Northern Caucasus still to a
lesser extent there are areas in which
the state but the rid of the state no
longer reads and so but it has a
localized dynamic and this is one of the
things I hope we take away from this is
that the we tend to care about Central
Asia because of Afghanistan and we tend
to care about Afghanistan because of the
threat of Islamic transnational
terrorism and I think there's a tendency
to paint with a very broad brush all of
these groups as of the same kind and
working together and I think this is a
misnomer
I think the groups are largely localized
reaction to the various policies of the
great powers I think there's very little
connection between the Northern Caucasus
and Afghanistan for example or for the
various groups that are so operating in
Central Asian Republics as well they
require much more nuanced response than
painting them all of the same caste and
I think this is one of the dangers is
that as we interface with these Central
Asian Republics one of the key cards is
to say back to us that they're fighting
Islamic terrorism they're fighting
transnational terrorism and they can use
that as a calling card to sort of
whitewash their particular human rights
abuses and actually extract more rents
from the United States or from Russia in
some cases and so well I think this is a
mistake I think these are very different
reactions very different insurgencies
that are reactions to these great power
policies and so just in summation what
are we looking at in terms of Central
Asia is it important it's certain not
the most pressing foreign policy issue I
would
even argue that Afghanistan is in some
ways been overplayed at least in the
threat of transnational terrorism as
well and I think part of the problem
with this region is that there are
there's very little strategy going on
but there's also very little effective
levers of power that it can do anything
about these particular conflicts in fact
what I think is happening is that many
of the tools we're trying to use are
making the conflicts worse not resolving
them and so and so and finally the
Central Asian leaders have figured out a
way of extracting severe concessions
from the United States from Russia in
this particular region and that it may
be actually easier to not scale up the
level of commitment to Central Asia but
to think about actually scaling it down
not just in terms of Afghanistan but in
terms of the Republic's in the region as
well and so on that hopefully
provocative note I'll turn it over to
the next discussion thank you good
morning I'm delighted to be here but I
feel completely inadequate in like a
fish out of water I am NOT a Central
Asian expert I am someone who's focused
on US military assistance and trying to
raise issues of medium to long term
concern about foreign military aid
programs in particular so I am here by
by dint of the fact that the Open
Society Institute asked me almost a year
ago to look into the issue of US
military cooperation with Central Asia
they did this I think because of a
conversation we had where I was
outlining dramatic shifts that were
taking place in the u.s. foreign
military aid architecture overall not
just with Central Asia but outlining for
them that I it was my perception anyway
that that a lot had changed and that no
one really had the full picture of what
was happening in terms of US military
security cooperation so they
commissioned me to write a study which I
prepared called US military aid to
Central Asia 99 to 2009 security
priorities Trump Human Rights and
diplomacy so the the subtitle there sort
of gives you the
the the the finding in a nutshell I
thought I've been briefing on this
report on Capitol Hill over the last
couple days and I thought from from a
Washington you know inside the beltway
perspective that I was giving the fifty
thousand foot view but I see now that
I'm and way down in the weeds such
somehow I'm way down in the weeds and
yet I'm not on the ground like Jason is
another Washington place I guess you'd
say so this report is disappointing to
me and that it's really just a first
take I will jump into some of the
findings in in one moment but what it
became in large part really was an
examination kind of a u.s. bureaucratic
politics and where the real locus of of
focus I guess you'd say on this military
cooperation relationship is and so that
the title of our meeting here today how
central is Central Asia I was thinking
well one place that Central Asia is is
you know first and foremost is with
CENTCOM the US Central Command so a lot
of what I did in this report was look at
and explain the relative importance and
priority of the growing shift in role of
CENTCOM in foreign policymaking in
general and certainly in the foreign
military policy making relationship in
particular over the last two decades
really this this trend of growing you
know the United States divides the world
into combatant commands there six
regionally focused combatant commands
the Central Command is the region that
includes
Central Asian states it also of course
includes Iraq and Afghanistan so even
within CENTCOM Central Asia is not
central not the most central thing the
two hot conflicts are but CENTCOM was
focused on raising Washington's focus on
Central Asia at a time when few else in
Washington were there's a kind of
fascinating book written by a Washington
Post journalist named Anna prease the
book is called the mission where she
traveled around with several of these
combatant commanders including generals
any in 1999 when he was going into the
region for the first time going to
detach Ken for the first time and he was
complaining about his inability
to get the State Department to get the
Secretary of Defense so his inability to
get the civilians at the Pentagon and
his chain of command focused adequately
on Central Asia which he saw to be a
very important focus in the then not so
hot but but but heating up a focus on
al-qaeda and the Taliban at any rate so
so what's been happening over the last
two years then is that these the
combatant commanders the the regional
commands like CENTCOM have been gaining
more and more authority within annual
military bills that are passed to
provide direct military assistance so
I'm kind of a good fellow into J and
that what I was trying to do is simply
get a full picture of what's going on so
the heart of this report is really a
table where I tried to document again at
I don't know somewhere between 50,000
and weed level where where the military
aid where the money was going was coming
from that was going to Central Asian
states and so there's a table in here
where I pick I have one year 2007 which
happened to be the most transparent year
I could find in in the period I was
looking at where I tried to fill in all
of the various State Department and
Department of Defense funded pots of
money providing military assistance
basically what I found is that no one
short of probably Kurt Donnelly and and
CENTCOM the the plans and policy
Directorate have a clear picture of what
we are doing even folks I've briefed at
the Pentagon and talked with the
Pentagon tell me that the opacity the
lack of transparency about what's
happening is not intentional obfuscation
it's that they just don't know that
there are so many new authorities and
initiatives that have been created and
provided that no one really has a full
picture so a lot of a lot of what we did
here was well I should I should jump to
the to the kind of summary findings
first of all traditionally the State
Department budget has been the source of
US foreign assistance in general and
military aid in particular as I said
these new DoD authorities and budget
lines have come up over the last 20
years in particular since nine
eleven they've been granted in
consecutive years by by the four by the
Congress and and the result now I found
was that in 2007 the year I could get
the best information for money out of
the DoD budget from from 19 different
programs 19 different budgets provided
at least a hundred million dollars in
assistance to central asian police and
military and border security forces by
comparison state department provided
about 38 million dollars so this is a
dramatic shift it's always been assumed
that the state department programs were
where the action is and there's still
the most prestigious they're still the
ones that that have the highest profile
certainly because I had a very hard time
finding information about these others
but but in in reality they've been
eclipsed in terms of the walking around
money the money that these combatant
commands have to throw at at issues of
first and foremost counterterrorism of
course which is the overarching
framework now but counter
counter-narcotics which was the
overarching framework in the in the
middle 90s when the US military
relationship with these countries
started and and and also for stability
and of course access to the theaters of
conflict and for access for the northern
distribution network so so that the
DoD's the largest source of the money
there's no there's no budget put forward
I've been briefing in Congress different
committees have responsibility for the
military assistance that comes out of
the State Department versus the military
assistance that's coming out of the
Department of Defense so there's no one
who actually has jurisdiction to
oversight these various pots of money
the Department of the DoD the
committee's that oversee the DoD foreign
policymaking and military aid role which
now again is you know almost three times
that of the State Department there are
two guys on that committee who have
oversight for this entire for the full
military foreign aid policies and
Central Asia is not you know central to
the global picture I'm sorry to say so
so there's no possibility for oversight
there's no possibility of even having a
discussion about the totality of what
the US is doing because it's it's
currently not presented in any kind of
or collected in any kind of unified
budget there are efforts by the CRS and
by a special coordinator at the State
Department to draw together all of this
aid but what they run up against is the
fact that the DoD redefines much of what
it's doing in Central Asia or elsewhere
as something other than military
assistance they define a lot of the
military contact programs training
programs joint military operations and
direct cash support for various security
units in many cases as being related to
u.s. combat operations in support of
Afghanistan and therefore not considered
military assistance so you have a kind
of definitional issue a culture issue
then you have this first of all
capturing what it is you're talking
about going to the region then you have
this bureaucratic political problem of
different largely well the fact that the
DoD is not held to account at all for
its budgetary expenditures in general
but but on this foreign military aid
piece as well so so right so we found
large scale you know the the DoD is
dominant in these programs that they've
raised the the priority of military
trained F training of foreign military
forces to that of a critical mission
just this year which means that they are
going to continue to prioritize foreign
military training of Central Asian and
other forces and therefore will continue
to seek and in today's climate get more
and more authority to provide more and
more aid so this trend is going to
continue this trend of the DoD being
more dominant in the policy making in
the budgetary expenditure which
therefore means in the in the
policy-making relative to to other
priorities in the region you know the
State Department has repeatedly
I said and I and is pursuing a project
of democratization and support for civil
society and open media and Central Asia
from the data we were able to gather
just on budgetary grounds there's six
dollars going to the police and security
forces for every $1 going for
democratization and human rights
programs writ large the the concern is
not only that there is no transparency
and democracy within the US budget and
policy making process about these
priorities but then obviously the
symbolic message on the ground is one of
you know much much greater and and the
real impact on the ground is one of much
greater us support for the security
forces of the regimes in Central Asia
then for the civil society programs
which themselves I'm perfectly willing
to believe are fraught with problems in
terms of unintended consequences but the
unintended consequences of dramatically
supporting the forces of governments
that we acknowledge have serious and
ongoing human rights problems is you
know I think not being confronted at all
in Washington as I said because in in
the first instance there's simply no
clarity no understanding of what the
actual budgetary and policy situation is
so I leave you with that and I know I've
brought you into my weeds I'm sorry
I think there's the moderator let me try
to sum up where I think there's some
consensus but also try to be provocative
and provoke a discussion and fights and
civil unrest among the panelists so I
think what I heard from the panel is
that first we need to think of Central
Asia writ large not just the five
post-soviet republics but we also need
to consider the broader implications of
Afghanistan Iran Pakistan India I think
there's general consensus on that that
for the great power Central Asia is not
in the directly in their sights but it
does touch on issues that are important
to them particularly rivalry among the
the great powers but it's not the the
the thing that Kidan when they wake up
first thing in the morning this is what
they're thinking about um that the
threat of Islamic fundamentalism is
overplayed I think was very interesting
that the only reference to Islamic
fundamentalism on the panel among the
four speakers was to say it's overplayed
I didn't even come up and some of the
others was I think quite interesting the
other that the aid policy in the region
has been counterproductive we heard that
in three of the four remarks and I just
wanted to push back a little bit on on
on that you know I think in order to say
that that Aid has been counterproductive
we need to think of what the
counterfactual will be without aid with
that without aid would it be easier for
these leaders to claim legitimacy
without aid would be easier for them to
build roads and two kinds of a you know
public works projects that that might be
well used it all depends on how how the
aid is used and how its monitored so I
wanted to push back a little bit on that
we've known for a long time in the aid
business that for every dollar you spend
building a road you need to spend ten
dollars to have an organization to
maintain and protect them protect that
road so this is not my area
I spend a lot of time thinking about
foreign aid but I haven't spent a lot of
time thinking about it in this context
but I just wanted to push back a little
bit on that view because we might think
that these types of eight bargains might
have some positive sides as well in
terms of allowing leaders to actually
stay in power the leaders with whom we
might have better relationships than the
the people that might follow after them
right we might think of a counterfactual
where somebody who was even more
difficult to deal with might come into
power and perhaps the rents that that
accrue to leaders if we called them pork
barrel spending we might think about
them differently which is really what
they are they are just a mechanism to
deliver benefits to people on whom they
then they need to stay in power so I if
Jason want to be provocative I want to
be countered for me being even more
provocative by and it's unusual for me
to be the you know a defender of foreign
aid um another thing I think is you know
spending six dollars on the police vs. a
dollar on democracy building I I'm very
comfortable with that the odds of
democratic success in this region I
think are very low one thing we you know
we don't know much in social science but
we know it's very difficult to build
democracies and poor ethnically divided
isolate isolated regions where
governance is poor and if we think you
know most countries even even without US
aid that are that are poor isolated
autocratic they tend to be very corrupt
as well even without even without our
benign interventions the other point I
want to push back a little bit on and
this is perhaps extracting a little bit
from what the speakers have said is it
seems that the importance of Central
Asia is really a function of how
important do you Afghanistan as a threat
to security interests either for China
Russia or for the United States and if
you view Afghanistan as less of a threat
then Central Asia you know it becomes
rational to say why are we pouring money
into the this place where leaders don't
share our goals and where the you know
what would our influence over what's
gonna happen in Afghanistan is it's not
all that great anyway so is and it might
even be counter might even be a counter
counterproductive and we might think
perhaps if the threats of might be more
likely to come from failed states
elsewhere as you know people who would
seek to do harm to the United States
migrate to places like Yemen and Somalia
perhaps we should be devoting more
attention to other types of failed
States where people who would like to do
harm to the US might enjoy a less
scrutiny from US military people at any
level so I just wanted to throw throw
these ideas out to the panelists and
also encourage them if there are any
remarks that the other panelists made
that they would like to address
apart from my comments - - feel free to
step in and then we'll take some
questions from the audience look I mean
I just pick up on your last point I do
believe that it is very difficult to
make the argument for Central Asia
person but part of the problem that we
do have in policymaking is our the way
we're structured bureaucratically is
that we can't put it in a broader
context and obviously these these five
states do not exist in isolation and if
you're even thinking about Central Asia
five states in fact as an artificial
construct I mean if you draw the lines
of what this really should look look
like it would extend into into
Afghanistan into parts of Iran the
caucuses parts of southern Russia
western China and so forth and if you
put that all together I think you can
make a credible argument that given the
forces at play given the the interest of
the great various great powers and
regional powers that you have a
combustible mix and that people need to
devote more attention to it now you know
this isn't necessarily something that's
going to explode in our faces in the
next year or two there are other issues
as well but if you play this out over
the long
I mean I think it's it's difficult to
see another part of the world where you
have as many great and major powers
involved with conflicting interest and
what we need to exercise our imagination
on is how a problem in Central Asia will
lead to the great powers ending up on
the opposite side in a conflict that
they think is vital to their national
security now I would argue that you know
if you if you take it in that context
it's hard to imagine a part of the world
that's more problematic I even if we
think about the Middle East where
clearly will be a lot of local conflicts
I find it hard to imagine a conflict
where the great powers will end up on
opposite sides so perhaps there are
opportunities for cooperation at least
as much as for a competition in the
region right but you know East Asia's
are the same you can go down the list
and that's why you know it's important
at this point that the United States in
particular given our involvement begin
to think about what the security
structures are that you need to put in
place to try to manage this competition
going forward all right they're elements
out there the things that we could play
with but the United States really hasn't
thought of it in those terms and even if
you look at our Afghanistan strategy it
was remarkable about the speech that the
president gave almost a year ago is how
little he talked about anything outside
of Afghanistan he he talked about
Pakistan mm-hmm
when he looked to the outside world it
was our European allies in Afghanistan
if NATO's test cases Afghanistan NATO is
going to fail I think that's clear but
he ignored all the countries in the
region whose interests our long-term who
can't avoid it that we need to organize
now the problem of course is that you've
got in Iran which is not exactly on
talking terms of the United States right
now yet a difficult relationship with
Russia but those things really shouldn't
get in the
way of thinking about how you manage is
going forward and we have a lot of other
levers that we can pull in our evolving
relationship with the Russians the
Indians Pakistanis and so forth that
could produce a long term diplomatic
solution and adequate regional structure
that's what we need to be focused on
just very briefly at addressing point J
mate and-and-and and Tom made so III
must actually agree with Jay and his
point about local elites leveraging the
strategic competition I see the to a
symbiotic I see as you know as the
engagement has intensified in the
region's over the last ten years local
elites have learned how to leverage this
more and more skillfully kind of thing
one thing I guess you know one area of
potential difference I have is I don't
see elites skillfully playing great
powers in and of itself as a sign of
institutional durability right in other
words I'm sort of I mean III take your
point about the caucuses to heart I was
just reading the other week a book from
another region Bob Bates his book when
things fell apart and and and the
argument it's on Africa and it's about a
very short book it's excellent it's
about just a macro trajectory post
independence of African states of going
from sort of trying to build States to
creating hegemonic political parties
with patronage machines to leaders
having shorter and shorter time horizons
when they just grabbed all they wanted
to for themselves and started you know
neglecting even the patronage outlets in
the parties and and you know obviously
analogies are imperfect but I see very
similar dynamics in Kyrgyzstan and
Tajikistan that yes you know the elites
have skillfully played off the great
parties but what is that the influence
been on sort of institution of
durability and and you know things are
stable until they're not and yes the
doomsday scenarios haven't come to pass
you're absolutely right but but you know
gosh I just see the violence in the
south of Kyrgyzstan what's happened in
Tajikistan over the last year you know
you're right to push back on the sort of
Islamic threat they're all coming at us
but but there's there's a level of
sophistication in in what we've seen in
activity in Tajikistan that
that you know I'm not sure and I I just
I just see Tajikistan I was out of money
out of options out of diversionary
tactics and the population that's really
sort of fed up so we'll see you know how
it goes going forward to Tom's point
about need for a new security
architecture I mean just look at and
justice to underscore this just look at
what happened in the aftermath of
Kyrgyzstan right both the coup changing
government whatever you want to call it
and the ethnic violence in the south
all of these regional security
organizations were discredited right in
terms of having the mechanisms to do
something about it csto here's a
textbook example instability an
invitation issued by a government right
and and and you know and the Russians
still wouldn't pull the trigger and look
concerned about who's back sort of
debates sort of internally about what
they should do it you're not gonna get a
better test case SCO very similar
dynamic I mean these are those kind of
scenarios that the SEO have been running
all other training exercises right
essentially sort of regime change
scenarios and how you would sort of deal
with that ineffective OSCE right we've
always sort of assumed the real problem
the OSC is that we have you know
us-russian rivalry now and pushback by
Russia on a lot of the sort of Western
conditioning agenda in the OSCE the
human rights and democracy monitoring
and so forth as it turns out here's one
issue area in which were relatively on
the same page in Moscow wanting to
stabilize this government and we still
can't get an agreement to send 50 cops
to ah Sh right so there's there's
there's a real I mean it terms
absolutely right of where are these
security architectures going to come
from and how are they going to deal with
uncovered areas or with areas that want
to check out of the formal kind of sort
of state system I think it's it's it's
very difficult to envisage what kind of
architecture that would look like but
just on the security architecture thing
I mean it seems like this is a little
bit of a cart in the horse right because
it's hard to build the architecture if
you don't know what you're building it
for and as we're sitting up here right
we're kind of talking about what's the
threat what's the challenge
and to me and maybe I have insufficient
imagination I'm just having a really
hard time thinking of wake what would
prompt a great power conflict
particularly now that the United States
has been in centralization for ten years
my sense is that the enthusiasm to do
this again is probably been waning at
least in the near term
and so it's not clear to me what would
the what's the problem that the
architecture is trying to solve and in
some ways Central Asia is a story of
everybody's got a security architecture
that's the problem there's like I mean
you know this better than any way
there's five of them and or four and so
this is me it's kind of like why isn't
there a better security architecture and
I guess the aunt the answer to me is
what's the what's the problem we're
trying to solve and and do we need a new
architecture and and and maybe we do
maybe we need to scrap all this it also
seems that the the great powers want
different things with their different
institutions and so I think this is
exactly why you don't have a more
effective architecture because they all
want to use it for their own so if your
power reasons until there's something
really pressing I don't think you're
gonna see an effective architecture now
to my thinking and this is to rope in
the Islamic fundamentalism question
which I thought was really just as a
gray I was really I didn't notice that
we didn't really talk about that much to
me that would have been one hook that
everybody would agree on right now in
some ways but but that hasn't been able
to spark any kind of real sustained
cooperation I mean there are some is you
know some collective exercise is there
is some collective architecture but I
think everybody just say they disagree
on what the nature of the threat is I
think too and so and they have very
different views on what Afghanistan
means you know the Russia has a very
different view towards what the Afghan
problem is the United States does as
does China and so again that doesn't
seem to be enough common leverage to a
common ground to create an architecture
and if you can have that as a security
threat to build it I just not sure what
the architecture would look like and
just finally the the question of the
counterfactual te I think it's a really
really interesting one I'm not sure I
have a very good answer detecting oh
yeah you know other than to say I think
the counterfactual is is not no aid
right it's a different kind of aid and I
think this is the the problem with
Afghanistan now and I think it might be
a problem writ large across the region
as your study shows there's a lot of
different aid projects all running at
the same time there's not much vetting
or evaluation of them some of them may
be working fantastically some of them
may be working disastrously we actually
can't tell apart be
such political incentive just to spend
the money and to show some kind of
effect whether it be you know a school
built or an output measure whatever we
don't typically look at what the effects
are and in fact now to some of the work
that I've seen being done in Afghanistan
I'm doing myself we're only now starting
to think of what do measures of
effectiveness actually look like for aid
and this is nine years into the conflict
and I think billions of dollars have
been spent and we're not clear what's
going on so I don't think the answer is
no aid I think it may be a of a
different sort of aid a different
sequencing of the a perhaps but there
can't just be this you know 30 programs
running in 30 different directions
delivering a lot of it I think that is a
recipe for disaster
we just need bags of cash we just to
give you an example that the commander's
Emergency Response Fund in our program
in Afghanistan it was a rock - I mean
this is what it was a suitcases of money
that you had - you have a short-term
project you'd find you need to show
effects in 30 days you show up with your
money and off we go
and something gets done right I think
this is not a reference to report right
this we're playing around spending more
money right I think this is not a good
way to be doing yeah actually I want to
mention is a piece by Hine Goldman's who
looks at autocratic regimes war
proneness and that personalist
types of autocracies a type of
government in which central asia is
uniquely rich are especially war prone
particularly when they border other
personalist autocracies another region
in which the central asia differs from
every other part of the world that
they're you know all the of these five
kind of personalist autocratic regimes
and they are especially war prone so in
terms of the possibility for internal
conflict among the Central Asian states
you know I think that you know going
forward this is a certainly something
that we need to keep our eye on any
questions from the audience is anybody
yeah do you want to go to the mic so we
can I can be sure that you're captured
for all eternity Nicola serene I'm a
lawyer I practice in New York I made my
living trying murder cases now we all
know that many a time in a murder case
eyewitness testimony is very important
it's of critical importance sometimes so
with that perspective and without
prejudice to the exit to the excellent
presentations that we have heard here I
just keep wondering why don't we have
somebody on the panel there from Central
Asia we're getting the the fourth panel
today is we have representative Central
Asia from Russia China and from the
United States so in balancing all and
choosing the types of pan I'll take this
question in balancing out all of the the
the different issues we have we have to
often have to make very difficult
choices about energy Kyrgyzstan security
international competition in the region
so we will get a central asian view late
later today so I'm Roger poo I'm the UN
representative of lawyers Without
Borders
I was curious as to the utility of the
OSCE and their election monitoring I've
been in an election monitor in
Azerbaijan and Georgia recently and I
was curious as to your comments as to
the utility I recall that I recently
heard the Turkish tent had a according
to nd I a fair election that surprised
me
and I thought that the conflict would
affect the the fairness and when we were
in Azerbaijan the OSCE took sort of an
aggressive language that they didn't
comply with their standards and
Azerbaijan made some effort to complain
about it they said you gave have more
favorable language for Armenia and they
killed the opposition we just put the
opposition in jail and when they when
they agreed not to run we let him out
but I wondered if you had some comment
on encouraging democracy through fair
elections we could take Eric do you want
to ask what we'll just take a couple of
questions from the audience first and
then we'll let the panelists respond to
all of them and Toto if we can you can
be very just say who you are and just
very briefly with your questions give
him time constraints Eric and Glen Chi
George Mason University thank you for
the presentations I had a question about
the actors in Central Asia themselves
and how they view international
relations in over a short analogy went
where I went to grad school it was 80%
men 20% women we should get together on
Friday and talk about the 20% but we
never really thought about what that 20%
thought about us so I'm wondering if
when we think about the five actors and
how they think about how we think about
them does that have any kind of causal
effect on the architecture of security
that we might design against this I'm
Brett suna Columbia my question is that
the discussion so far has been mainly
focused on the u.s. level or at least
national level national level
perspective but to meet EU and NATO seem
important or least relevant actors in
the region - so my question is whether
or
hoping at least that you could comment a
little bit on this NATO or EU u.s.
perspective initial great you're taking
good notes
yeah I'm Tom Symons I'm with the Davis
center I follow Central Asia among other
things and I'm a retired diplomat my
questions are two-word an energy go
because five years ago certainly 10
years ago if you talked about Central
Asia and security you talked a lot about
energy access to the world markets
pipelines that's kind of disappeared
from the discussion and I wonder if you
guys think it's gotten better or if so
in what way
I think the second is your in terms of
volatility in the including the Islamic
threat which I agree I teach us long
post communist Islam I also think it's
overrated but you are treating seem you
seem to be treating all five countries
on these issues as kind of equivalent
whereas really in terms of state
weakness and volatility you're talking
about Kyrgyzstan and Tajikistan you
haven't really talked about the others
two of them have major resources with
which to buy buy off popular discontent
and maybe even Islamist extremism but
the picture you paint of Central Asia is
really a picture of the two states with
the weakest state structures and the
most political turbulence very different
kinds over the last 15 years and I'd
invite your comments on that distinction
hello first of all things for your great
integrations and my name is Eric part of
15 fellow from the day TV Center have
merely two questions which will be going
back to the big question which is like
which gonna be the architecture secure
architecture innocent relation mainly
relating to Afghanistan because part of
the reasons the main problem for the
United States so if in the United States
is live in from Afghanistan is it viable
is it possible that it should really
think about let's say outsourcing the
stability to other organizations like
SCO
and if that's not realistic would be
that's very challenging but would be
more realistic to think that Afghanistan
could be could neutralize itself in a
perpetual civil war that would not cause
like any trouble abroad which is of
course very risky thank you
let's just take three more quick
questions and then well then we'll cut
it off and yes I have been teaching
about Central Asia and the main
challenge to understand Central Asia and
in kind of innovative way is to remember
that Central Asia is not not one entity
it has five very different actors and
today I have an expression from this
panel that you talk about Central Asia's
one entity but we have five different
very different players moving very
different directions and having you know
a very different view about relationship
with United States with Russia with
China so can we add this complicity that
five different players have different
ideas and if it won't like to be
different relations United States to
explain better you know to explain
what's going on in relations in our case
for example what the panel talks about
between United States and Central Asian
individual placed individual republics
thank you I feel like we're jumping out
of an airplane
mark millar from the kyrgyz north
america trade council I had a question
regarding to the panel asking if anybody
on the panel sees hope and spreading the
rent seeking opportunities to the
entrepreneurial classes in the region
rather than just the political or tribal
leadership especially commercial
opportunities surrounding ndn and
related related issues thank you ade and
how policy and actions are decided based
on what the examiner wishes to see I
wonder if you can be called into
question for doing the same thing
because we don't have any central agents
on your
and like the gentleman who's the lawyer
said eyewitnesses are very important to
the issues thanks a lot for great
questions they're too much too difficult
for me to answer so I'll turn them over
to the panelists I think part of the
issue is that the energy equation in
Europe has changed over the past several
years particularly with the economic
crisis also the potential it's right in
my microphone it's not if you get a
little closer on shale gas and how that
might be a game-changer and so forth so
from the European perspective which is
largely the perspective at which the
United States has looked at the gas
situation and the the Caspian region it
has a lesser I would think profile in
the US government now than it might have
had two or three years ago I still think
energy is important but it's important
because of the growth in India and China
in particular and a need to service
those markets and it's not an accident
that China has built the pipeline's
across the Central Asian it's mark is
that in fact undermine of the Russian
monopoly of export around out of Central
Asia that I think is a significant
development and something that we
haven't probably paid enough their
attention to in the United States
quickly on Europe and NATO my own view
may be wrong is that I can't think of a
part of the world has less interest and
what really happens in Central Asian and
the EU and NATO and hinging the success
of our strategy in Afghanistan on
assistance from from NATO is nuts
they'll be out before we are in part
because the public doesn't support it
the public with European public
supported activities in Afghanistan as
long as we were building democracy that
is not where the US is and I think
that's not where most countries in the
region are at this point so I think
you're going to see waning NATO support
for this and
I said if this is going to be a measure
of the success of NATO we're going to
have to reconcile
on Central Asia and why we don't have
Central Asians on the panel I take the
point but this was a look from the
outside into Central Asia and how
outside powers and think about their
interests there the Central Asians
obviously are players in all of this
their attitudes are our important issue
as you try to formulate policies to try
to think through what your own interests
are what the challenges are but one of
the reasons that Central Asia and South
Asia will become a challenge to the
international environment is that you've
got a lot of policymakers in Beijing
Moscow Delhi Chiron and Washington who
don't know anything about the region
even if they still can locate it on the
map
very quickly election monitoring so the
deal with election monitoring after 2005
is Jay talked about sirs the the push
back election monitoring started to be
perceived as an instrument to regime
change right in these places especially
have the colored revolutions so regime
started treating election monitors with
deep suspicion and they jumped on board
the Russian proposal to reform the OSCE
kind of election monitors effectively
sort of watering it down if you speak to
some OSC people at the oh dear they'll
admit to the fact that you know what
maybe there is some truth to the double
standards me maybe we weren't pushing as
hard in Spain or the us as we were these
Eastern and Central Asian countries kind
of thing but but you know election
monitoring has been defamed from from
what it was in the 90s and early 2000s
on the EU look III think the EU has a
strategy and Germany has a strategy but
it just doesn't have a lot of buy-in and
you just aren't funding it to the degree
that you need to to get the kind of
sustained engagement in this sort of
list of things that you want
I would reverse it what and and ask what
effect has Central Asia had on the EU
right the debates over sanctions on news
Beca stand I think have been some of the
toughest I've seen in Brussels in terms
of what is the EU is that a strategic
actor is it a normative actor how does
it deal with areas that are
gonna become members and doesn't have
the leverage of conditionality so I
think the reflection goes sort of both
ways and Uzbekistan issue was
particularly tough on the SEO in
Afghanistan you know the problem here is
that you don't have consensus in China
and Russia what to do in Afghanistan so
if you don't have consensus the two
biggest SEO members how you gonna have a
go here at SCO policy it's not gonna
happen very finely on Rufus's point
about you know are all of these are
different countries yeah that's
absolutely true and and I think we've
hinted at some of the local issues sort
of simmering in terms of water politics
and so forth but I think there is a
commonality and that is the increasing
trend towards multi-vector ISM in
foreign policies on all of them right
whether it's accepting multi bases
whether it's happinesses multi pipelines
whatever it is you know happiness is a
Eurasian identity you're not Western
Eastern or something sort of in between
that attempt to carve out the
flexibility in your foreign policy I
think is a defining a hallmark of all
the Central Asian countries but I take
the point about not having Central Asian
representatives here just very very - I
think Central Asia I think we're
actually what we're doing on the panel
is redefining what it is I mean when I
first got invited to the panel I had to
go look up with Central Asia woods
because I wasn't sure what was in the
common currency because Afghanistan is
not considered part of the Caucasus and
now there's Pakistan right in and Iran
and yet they're all players in the
region - and I think we're actually
coming to it a very different
understanding than just the five former
Soviet republics and so I mean I don't
I'm not sure we actually know where
Central Asia is yet other than it's
probably not just the five former Soviet
republics just very quickly on the
utility of the election monitors a lot
of fascinating me that these these
regimes continue to use elections
because they occasionally get a snake
bit on them that the elections can
sometimes be coordinating events for
people who are disgruntled to actually
go after the regime they can use as a
focal point now some of it worked by
Joshua Tucker for example it is very
interesting on this some of the things
we do find from the studies is that they
typically do
catch a little bit of fraud they make
the election somewhat more reliable but
but what it's actually sometimes does it
just shift the level of fraud prior to
when the election monitors actually come
in so it's not about boxed stuffing
exercise anymore if
rod goes upstream and it's either
jailing people or different kinds of
corruption so in some ways it may not be
as effective at making free and fair
elections it just changes the nature of
fraud and corruption that's actually
going on on the role of NATO and EU in
Afghanistan I think this is a really
important question I think NATO is is
pretty much falling apart now in
Afghanistan the Germans will leave in
part where it's interesting some of the
earlier connections to the north of
Afghanistan that's really where the
Germans are operating right now they do
not want to do this anymore the area's
become incredibly violent it was a
vacuum for a long time it was stable for
a long time partly because of no Taliban
now Taliban I moved the Germans have a
fairly large contingent they're about
ready to leave the British have the
second largest contingent after the
Americans are about ready to leave
Canadians have the third largest
contingent and they're about ready to
leave - and I spent this summer at IFA
HQ and the mood among most people
they're not just the Europeans but
particular many European says is it's
time to go this has been long enough and
it's not working the other thing is
you're getting a very patchwork quilt
and NATO in Afghanistan on strategy
there's different national level
strategies because even to the point
where the data reporting standards on
what's going on is different across they
still haven't synced the data between US
side NATO side she's hard to get
resolution on what's going on and so I
think actually when people look back at
the NATO experience with the United
States and Afghanistan it would be a
textbook case of failure of command that
you're supposed to have unity of command
in a counterinsurgency environment this
is anything but and then finally the
really insane questions about why not
why not send money to the or shift aid
opportunities to the political elites
rather than they commercial are excuse
me to the commercial rather than to the
political I think it's really
interesting because in a lot of these
environments those two distinctions are
not necessarily so clear and some of the
most commercial or entrepreneurial
actors on the ground all the people who
create the security organizations that
portrayal patrol the roads or provide to
explain security who are often
interwined with intertwined with the
families who are controlling the country
or who have political connections
otherwise and so separating out Commerce
and politics and trying to target one
but not the other is incredibly
difficult in these situations and so
okay I just want to say thanks I wanted
to wrap up with one comment and steal
from Tom Graham who was at a conference
last year where he said we were also
discussing central asia and he said you
keep people keep mentioning post-soviet
Central Asia I keep thinking of pre
Chinese Central Asia which i think is in
keeping with the discussion of how we
define Central Asia plays a big role in
how we view the security challenge is
there so I want to thank everybody for a
great panel and great questions from the
audience we'll reconvene at 10:45 with
whether the panel of another stellar
group of speakers on energy so thank you
very much